let me say a few people adjustable words
and then you'll say summary for its
introducing
just to give you a warning I thought
that as we introduce ourselves we could
try to not just say our names
institutions whenever but something that
you might want to say about the workshop
what you're hoping to get out of it what
we might hope to achieve etc and also if
possible to try to say at least one
thing you'd be willing to change your
mind about over the course of the next
three days I know so welcome to the Red
Lion Inn it seems like a great place
thanks to Steve for suggesting it like I
realized it was the best place when I
went to gift shop I found wash away your
sins hand soap greed kills sins on
contact for liars cheaters and
wrongdoers reduces guilt by ninety eight
point nine percent or more you say Jesus
[Music]
wash away your sins so logistical things
we have the daily agenda listed up here
we have these topics we're gonna be very
flexible about all this although we've
left a lot of time for coffee breaks and
dinner and so forth and lunch so if we
can start at nine o'clock tomorrow that
would be awesome lunch we have
reservations downstairs in the main
dining room for this group so we will go
to those tables dinner is completely
free but there's a couple of dining
options here if many people probably
just want to stay here for dinner that
we can try to get reservations all those
together in the main dining room I think
that's the only place please check all
of us at once the Mafia will be
delivered what else we need to say about
food and things like that nothing I
don't think so it should be obvious that
we're filming the proceedings and
they'll just be put up on YouTube it's
not going to be broadcast on TV or
anything like that it's the new media
and we're doing it I'm in charge and
this is he our camera guy Pete Souza has
done this before
so he knows what he's doing and so you
know on the one hand it is true
that filming things and putting them on
the internet makes us more cautious in
our pronouncements on the other hand if
if you throw caution to the wind and say
something that you later regret just let
us know and it will not appear don't be
too that way and we think that the
technology set up here is ideal so there
are power strips on both sides if you
want to power your computer for the
filming and so forth it should be in the
background you don't even notice and
likewise these microphones you don't
need to speak into they just pick up the
sound of the room so almost all of our
conversation I think will this be us
here around the table talking to each
other if you want to use slides if you
want to use the footboard they're
completely available you know we don't
discourage that but I think that it's
fine just to talk like this for most of
the time oh yes some of us in the room
are very technologically advanced so
we've already settled on our twitter
hashtag for the meeting it is move
naturalism and will ve naturalism people
asked you know is it okay to blog live
tweet anything like that yet yes you can
just you know there's no secrets I don't
think of anything we're saying we're
saying here okay so I also wanted to
introduce Nick Pritzker to everyone
who's helped very generously helped us
support the meeting and the USA
um yeah well in my role as so as angel
and fly on the wall
I just want to recount a short dub
incident about 15 years ago I was with
Andre Linda one of my idols and I asked
Andre if I were willing to drop my
career as lawyer and and hotel ei and
and tech investor and devote myself
entirely to study cosmology would I be
able to understand his articles and he
said forget it
he said you're too old to start you do
did way better just to be a generalist
and look at things on a very superficial
basis and it makes a lot of sense and
then he asked me about about the hindu
cycle of life and death so in that
regard i followed his advice
and I in in my belief that if you bring
a lot of very smart people together in
different fields that focus on a topic
you may be able to shed a lot of light
on that topic then Sean and Jennifer
have helped me in that regard so I'm
very happy to sponsor this and in terms
of what I'm willing to change my mind
about I may be wrong they're bringing a
lot of smart people together change my
mind on that that's up to you Richard
well actually let me go first I okay
sorry the children those are the
logistical details and so in the spirit
of being maximally disorganized and
willing to spontaneously assemble let's
start inducing ourselves and we can ask
questions based on what each other is
saying and if this ends up being the
whole first day session that's fine the
first day is a fairly loose topic we're
in the morning we're talking about what
is real and what reality is made of it
in the afternoon we talk about emergence
and complexity and evolution and things
like that so they blend into each other
it's not very structured so I'm Sean
Carroll I'm a physicist by training or
actually I'm an astronomer by training
all of my degrees are in astronomy and
I've never been employed as an
astronomer but I've been interested also
in philosophy since I started philosophy
minor as an undergraduate sat in on
courses with John Rawls and Robert
Nozick as a graduate student but I was
told correctly that you know as a
graduate student you're supposed to not
think about anything other than what you
are studying but I've maintained
interest in these things I've written a
couple of papers about the relationship
between science and religion and saying
that being a good scientist beats you to
not be religious and I did as a young
assistant professor a book publisher
walked into my office he was sort of
tapping on doors at the physics
department at the University of Chicago
saying is anyone want to write a popular
book and I said well I I don't have any
plans but if I do write a popular book I
don't want it to be about physics I want
to write about atheism and he was
intrigued by that he went back to his
publisher and he came back and said
nobody would ever buy a book about so it
turns out that was wrong but I I think
that various people including people in
this room have been a
wonderful job making atheism naturalism
an idea that the world is what we
observe and that's all that is real much
more out there in the public discourse
as we were talking about on the car ride
up there's some feeling among many
people that that explaining why
naturalism is right and how science
leads us to that pulls the rug out from
underneath you
in terms of why we are here what is the
purpose and meaning of life and so forth
and all we have to offer them in return
is a hard concrete floor and I don't
think that's true I think we can do
better but so I'm very very interested
in sort of taking those positive next
steps and explaining to people what it
is like to live in a world governed by
naturalism and we don't all agree you
know we've had books come out Sam Harris
wrote a book that was very interesting
and he sends his regrets he couldn't be
here but you tried to make the case that
we can base morality on science and some
of us disagree with that and but this is
something we should at least have an
informed set of perspectives about and
so I had the idea having this little
meeting
I was very very pleased at the
enthusiastic response that everyone
received so I'm very happy to have you
all here and if there's one thing I'm
willing to change my mind about
tentatively it's freewill so I know the
freewill is one of the contentious
topics we can talk about I am a
compatible list I think that there's no
problem talking about freewill even
though we're all made of atoms obeying
the laws of physics but my belief in
that is based on the idea that talking
about human beings as rational choice
making agents is the best theory we have
of talking about human beings at the
level of human beings so if someone
convinces me we have a better theory of
human beings in which they are not
making rational choices that I'm
certainly willing to change my mind
thinking was anything else yeah if you
know if there's no such thing as a free
lunch maybe the problem is not whether
there's will but whether it's free
Richard
I'm Richard Dawkins I read zoology at
Oxford my interest was rather more
philosophical than Natural History I
always was interested in the deep
questions of existence why we here
what's it all about
what is life where does it come from and
so on
most of my but well I think well but one
of my books has been about evolution
probably for that reason my final job
was Charles Simoni professor of the
public understanding of science and so I
have an interest in science education
and I have an obvious interest in
naturalism atheism if you ask me
what would make me change my mind I
would like to be able to say that it
would be possible to change my mind
about naturalism itself the problem is I
have a hard time imagining what anything
but naturalism would look like and
presumably the opposite of naturalism is
supernaturalism
how could you even conceive of
demonstrating supernaturalism and so I
although I lay that out as being a thing
that I would like to be able to say I
could change my mind about I I can't on
the face of it imagine what that change
of mind would would look like because
the very word supernaturalism seems to
me to be incoherent and and actually
meaningless own only because oppa buzz
broad-minded open like a scientists are
supposed to be ready and willing to
change their minds if new evidence comes
in evidence could possibly look like
yeah I mean I mean that would that's the
obvious one and and and I've even
written about about that but the the
problem with that is it's far far more
probable to be a hoax not on a host
I mean Craig Venters genome in his
bacterium actually says this was made by
C Venter and if not by anyone on on
earth I mean it's I mean it seems to me
that quick and Ogle's that speculation
about directed panspermia and therefore
a signature from outer space is far more
probable than anything supernatural
because supernatural yeah we could Libra
no superhuman we could call it yes
[Music]
okay I'm dawn Ross I was done I did my
PhD in philosophy of science but I've
been variously held published in
philosophy and economics for the last
money here at the moment I was a endow
philosophy department as recently as
2010 but at the moment I'm exclusively
into economics department is a team I'm
[Laughter]
in I've been interested in the
unification of economics with other
sciences and by that I don't just mean
analytic unification in fact I don't
mean analytic unification at all I mean
understanding both large and small
economic systems as the as the
information processing systems that they
are and understanding how such
information processing systems fit into
the larger domain of information
processing systems in the world
the in I also have recently moved
reading a book with the philosopher
physics James ladyman called everything
must go
metaphysics naturalized and the argument
of that book is that philosophers for
the most part analytic philosophers
particularly have to really promote
naturalism in and give it its proper
innings because of lingering commitments
to pre-scientific worldviews so even
even many of the philosophers who are
most vociferous and insisting but David
Lewis for example who are most
vociferous in insisting that they take
contemporary physics seriously seem to
us not to take contemporary physics
seriously at all
right that what we actually find and and
and we try to diagnose a specific set of
commitments that we find in in most
analytic philosophy of analytic
metaphysics specifically which is a
commitment to the idea that the world is
ultimately made of little things and the
dynamics and processes in the world
result from those little things crashing
into each other
but those little things are having
distinctness independently of models of
the world as a whole so the book starts
with a sustained attack on analytic
philosophy analytic metaphysics we argue
that it as practiced in the worlds the
bets our best philosophy departments
right now it's virtually all nonsense is
it virtually all presupposes
demonstrably false physics we then have
a couple of chapters on quantum field
theory arguing that it's trying to tell
how the quantum field theory is in fact
inconsistent with the presuppositions of
most analytic metaphysics then a couple
of chapters in which we've tackled the
problem well so if we take real physics
seriously instead of that stylized fake
physics of analytic metaphysics what
about the special Sciences what are the
status of one of the status of that they
look like they're about objects of
various kinds they seem to be
generalizing over classes of objects in
the earlier chapters we've rejected
reductionist accounts of those objects
but at the same time naturalism we also
have we also argue against so-called
disunity theories so we argue the world
it is it is one of the set think the
reasonable things to ask of science that
it provide us with a general worldview
and a general worldview implies a work
of view of one world so if one takes
real physics seriously what about
special Sciences so we deal with that in
an information theoretic using
information theoretic mathematics though
not as satisfied with those chapters
chapters really are waystations because
they're basically where they're very in
English and one of our arguments is we
really can't expect we shouldn't expect
to be able to say true and interesting
things about the general structure of
the universe in natural language but at
least we do in that we do to try to do
it in that but at that point of the
infinite in that point of our dialectic
we are still talking to philosophers in
one sense we're trying to show how we've
got alternative views
consistent with our new foundations of
the favorite topics of analytic
metaphysicians so but we're now in the
business of writing up more popular and
accessible version of that book which we
hope to have out in a few years because
it's pretty formidable well you're
you're you're already doing the work for
us Massimo so maybe we could yeah um so
uh I'll stop and then the other the
other main thing we do have note this
once this may or may not turn out too
well I'm sure I was at some point say
things that that come from this base so
I just mentioned we do it I run a
experiment like an onyx lab at the
University of Cape Town and also has
partnered with Georgia State University
we don't do behavioral economics in the
sense most people are familiar with that
we're not trying to extract
psychological properties of individual
people we do experiments with large
groups of people because we're
interested in the in economic
information processing dynamics at the
population level we do sometimes put
people in fMRI scanners but even there
we're not interested in estimating their
individual properties we've got some
fancy some fancy econometrics for
scaling up to populations as for things
that I could change my mind about I hope
that I will change my mind I'm looking
forward to changing my mind about
philosophy of mathematics because I have
a different philosophy of mathematics
every month so I'm sure I'm not going to
get through three days or talking with
all you people and come up with the one
I started I came in with Alex Rosenberg
I started out as a physics student and
made a conceptual mistake which led me
into philosophy um I was cured of the
mistake by David Hume but it was too
late to go back into physics and I ended
up working in the falsity of economics
for a long
but economists were never interested
what in what anybody had to say about
the problems in their own discipline so
I moved through the philosophy of
biology long ago and I'm mainly hoping
to be able to keep my mouth shut and
listen to at this meeting because the
thing that I could change my mind about
is fairly radical um my own view is that
naturalism is really deeply incompatible
with what Wilfrid Sellars called the
manifest image and I'm sure that
philosophers around this table will help
non philosophers understand what is
meant by the manifest image and of
course there are people around this
table who insist that it is compatible
with large chunks of the manifest image
and if they could change my mind
then I would be very happy people can
you just give us the one yeah please so
the manifest image is a intelligent
sophisticated well informed version of
common sense of view about the furniture
of reality that reflects what most
people believe it is without being
supernatural except fair down
good and and I've written a book called
the atheist guide to reality not my
title my title was reality the rough
guide but unfortunately my agent told me
that the rough guide was a term that had
already been copyrighted by somebody
else and in this book I have argued in a
sustained way that naturalism commits us
to reject almost all of the manifest
image and that's why I would like to
have my mind changed I'm Owen Flanagan
and I'm a philosopher also just do good
I've been trying to change good luck but
Dan and I will try
so I actually been interested I guess I
can start with what Alex said is I've
always been interested in in this
question about Sellars has this quote
that a lot of us naturalist and
philosophy use where he says that
philosophy is the attempt to think about
how things hang together in how things
conceived up in the broadest possible
sense hang together in the broadest
possible sense and as some of the people
have said I mean it would be nice to
have a unified theory about how things
work and it does seem that as a cultural
project one of the problems is somehow
meshing if we can are a scientific
understanding of things with what it's
best preserved from common sense so I'm
interested I've always been interested
in that project autobiographically maybe
it's relevant to say I grew up as a good
little Catholic boy interested in
questions like why is there why is there
one
what about reward and Punishment what
about freedom and what about what
happens after life and in the same
section of the world where Rebecca was
growing up was a nice Jewish girl
probably asking the same questions but
in a different context and so I was I
would this by the time I I became I was
in college I was interested in what I
came to see is primarily scientific
questions about how did how did life
emerge hadn't sentient life emerge and
so I did increasingly go to the sciences
by the time I finished college
my teachers half of them thought that I
should go on in philosophy and having
them thought I should go on an
experimental psychology I realized if I
had gone in on an experimental
psychology I wanted to do brain science
but there really wasn't in 1970 brain
science it was still something before
that so I did the next best thing and
I've been attached to the naturalistic
program since then I studied with Lauren
Orman Quine and some of his students and
and my conception of naturalism has been
this idea that the best philosophy is
continuous with the best science perhaps
in a more general level the specific
problems I've been interested in are the
problem of consciousness and my attitude
about consciousness is that by the
mid-1990s when after people like Dan and
myself and a few other people
philosophers had their say about saying
consciousness could be made safe for
science that our work as philosophers
was pretty much done and then it's just
empirical questions of working out the
scientific details and I'm disturbed by
the way philosophers continue to go on
and moan and groan about
the hard problem and the impossibility
and conceivability thought experiments
and what if there and and it's
disturbing to me about my own field the
other area besides consciousness i've
been interested in and this is again
work I did in the early nineties was on
ethics and always been interested in
this question of whether or not so I
wrote a book around the same time I
wrote a book on consciousness on what I
called varieties of moral personality
ethics and psychological realism and was
and the idea was that ethics could be
naturalized there was just no problem
there was no reason to think that we had
to think of morality either in
Supernatural istic terms or in morally
realistic terms or as my general view is
what in is roughly that you know
morality is just another social
institution and due to the certain bad
effects of theological traditions we've
come to think of it as something which
requires a separate sort of explanation
I continue to work on that I think that
I always very curious about the way that
everybody gets the heebie-jeebies about
what they allege to be Humes problem the
problem of relativity the problem of how
you derive is from off the answer is you
don't derive instrument because that
would be a fallacy but you can make
inferences the best explanation about
what you ought to do or what is
reasonable to do or what will make life
go best or what it enhances well-being
and there are often competing goods
about this the these two interests in
naturalizing mind and naturalizing
morality have led me in some recent work
and this is back to the little boy that
i once was to what I call the really
heart problems and I think these are
really hard problems for natural ists
what I call mind morals in the meaning
of life and by that I just mean making
this is partly a cultural project of
of taking seriously the fact that most
of our compatriots on earth are not or
at least in America start with just
America have trouble seeing how life
could make sense or be meaningful if the
world is as most of the people around
the table think and I try in some of my
most recent work to give a kind of an
upbeat explanation of how it's possible
to find meaning in a fully material
world one other interest I have and then
I'll close with what I could change my
mind about is I'm actually very
interested in the way other traditions
conceive of the world the natural world
the place of science in it and whether
they have the same problems as us so for
example I I've been working for a long
time recently well for a long time sort
of secretly and then lately more
publicly in classical Chinese and
classical Indian philosophy and so I'm
be interested in the discussions of
freewill here because I am one of those
people who think that it's a black hole
and philosophy and that other cultures
happily avoid discussing it and it just
doesn't come up and I'm thinking here of
Hindu and Buddhist traditions classical
Chinese philosophy it just doesn't come
up and some people are trying to say
here's what Buddhists would think if
they talked about free will and I'm
saying shut up don't even talk about it
they're better off or not even bringing
it up so I'll be I have some things to
say about that
and finally what I would change my mind
about so I've been there's a literature
in psychology that maybe people in this
room know about I know Dan certainly
knows better and I'm sure Rebecca this -
it's a literature on what's called
positive illusions and the positive
illusion literature basically says
something like this
that you know the findings are things
like this that you you introduce you
give a public health lecture at the
beginning of you know the Stanford
undergraduates arrive and you say you
women in the room the chances of getting
breast cancer in your life or one and
eight so here are some things you can do
for breast health and men it's one a day
for prostate cancer here's some things
you should do for prostate and then you
ask the students afterwards what is the
probability of you getting having the
bad things happen to you and always in
the population you they get back much
lower rates of believing that this thing
will happen to them then they should get
back obviously some people will know
they're late greater or lesser risk but
in a population you should get back the
base rate which you just reported to
these smart people and the findings are
that you never get back the base rate
you get back lower and then when they
pull out the subgroups this is the
allegation that when you pull out these
different groups the only group that are
what they call realists about things are
people who are moderately depressed the
people who are very depressed of course
think they already have the disease but
I think this is interesting now Dan has
given an explanation of trying to argue
that these kinds of positive illusions
are our adaptive I think that's
preposterous but it's really a hope I
have more than anything else I'd like to
think that maybe these things are hopes
instead of beliefs in which case they'd
be less rational it's kind of like I'm
not answering the question do I believe
that I won't get that I'm saying I hope
I don't get that so but I've been
working in this for a long time and I
can't get back out of the way and the
reason they're relevant to a group like
this and this is what I could change my
mind about steven weinberg many years
ago when I read one of his wonderful
articles I think Steven said something
like it's obvious and it's that religion
has done more harm than good and that's
the view I tend to have and I tend to
have the view that believing false
things does always more harm than good
but I worry about my belief there I
worry about that belief
so I guess I the thing to say is what I
could change my mind about I get stuck
in that middle easily some days I think
false beliefs are always the enemy and
then when I speak to the front of
psychologists they say you philosophers
are weird and maybe you scientists or do
you care about the truth most people
don't care about the truth and it's
actually even bad for them so I think
that these are this is a topic where I
could go either way on and I I love to
sit here and get your wisdom on so do
you know what the students would say if
they if they were asked why do you think
you'll have a 2% chance even though we
love you that's one in eight
you know there's a lot of I've read a
lot of this literature over time David
an could speak to that I don't know what
they say people tell me it's really that
the my explanation which tries to give
the they hope it's a it's a it's a
misattribution they're really hoping it
rather than belief believing it you
think you could get that right Sean by
doing further study I don't remember the
last time I looked at this research
whether anyone's done the further study
I don't know yeah thank you so I'm
signing today oh I was trained as a
physicist so actually like Sean I
realized that all my degrees are in
astronomy as well than I did cosmology
to Chicago which is very much done and
while I was at Chicago I became
increasingly interested in branching out
I had read of course many of the books
written by people in this room and I
ended up doing a lot of work in animal
and human behavior and ended up at the
Santa Fe Institute and it's actually
it's much easier to study human behavior
because humans leave records of their
behavior everywhere and because I was a
cosmologists I had no problem studying
historical events that I couldn't do
experiments on or social systems that
are so large you can't do experiments on
so I had none of the I never work in a
lab I don't see why you need to work in
a lab to learn on your own
and so yeah I being having grown up as a
physicist I was a plate in history
probably still in and one of the things
I do when I work on social systems is I
try to take the methods and ontology zuv
physics very seriously and in physics of
course you can have objects and believe
they're they
no composit parts and then later you
discover they have composite parts and
this is not distressing at all that
you've discovered the proton is is not
an elementary particle so when you come
to study social systems often and I
should say hi when I was an
undergraduate I took a class with Hilary
Putnam who was I didn't know this but he
was a functionalist and I didn't know
you had to invent functionalism it just
seems so obvious that it had to be true
that the brain was a computer and that
you should understand thoughts mental
states the sort of objects of moral
intuitions as computations and so it was
striking to me that it had to be
invented by somebody and that person was
in the room and okay oh that's that's a
tough one I just gave the introductory
lecture on this subject in my intro
course so I could well any workings babe
but well the the idea that mental states
what we consider to be the the act of
thinking is multiple realizable in
different objects as long as the the
structure that object has the the the
sub parts that objects have the same
functional roles as the original let's
say brain that you're modeling it's I
think the the intuition behind why we
think artificial intelligence is as
possible exactly so there's all sorts of
you know I take your neurons I spy
slowly replaced them by small silicon
chips that do the same thing I make it
Bluetooth I take a little box that's
your brain right all the things that are
performing the computation the biology
of the IO is sort of extraneous what
we're striking so but maybe it matters
what maybe it matters how they're
embedded in the world right so it's just
me or structural ice and morphisms
probably not not enough so this is this
was actually it so the the fact a that
had to be invented in the fact that he
was not talking about the Twinner
thought experiment which we can talk
about as well but the the idea that
actually this might not be true that
thinking just staying in the head was
his phrase
we should be nice to computers well so
this is this is this is an excellent
question so this one maybe get to what
seems to me to be the strange fact about
naturalism I think if you are a
naturalist you you you you take a
century functional position if I
download you in your computer I have to
treat that computer with respect I can't
delete you but when I came to study
social systems I hiding the hybrids I
would archive all of you but no so one
of the things that's striking is okay
fine you if you know the brain is a
computation I can find lots of
computations and social systems and I
think first of all this is the solution
to some of putnams objections to pure
internal functionalism but when I study
a social system I I sort of reverse
engineer it I try and find the
underlying computation sometimes those
computations involve multiple brains at
the same time and that to me seems very
strange so there's a computation that
floats around it's not attached to any
particular person what's it like to be
that computation and I I don't have a
good answer for that well I I you know I
know what it's like to be me I feel
although it's funny we talk about the
Buddhists intuitions one of my students
I was trying to explain when I was gonna
say to you guys to her and she has said
a lot of Eastern philosophy and none of
this made sense to her the intuition
that there are mental states that mental
states have functional relationships to
each other and so I had a conversation
with somebody who claimed not to have
mental states which is the opposite of
the zombie intuition where everyone's
trying to convince you they do have
mental states and you know experiences
of what it is like to be somebody so in
any case that is sort of a roundabout
way to say that I do a lot of
mathematics and the Social Sciences but
I do it from as if I was a physicist
sorry I used I used tools like group
theory if you go into the social
sciences from what you might call the
hard sciences everyone expects you to be
very good predicting things because
that's the gold standard if you can
predict how organism is going to behave
and if they think you know what it means
and I tend to focus much more on
explanation so that's that's one of the
sort of distinctions that I make
whenever I have to explain
when I do in a pedagogical system so any
Casey I suppose if I was willing to give
something up or what I might be willing
to change my mind on you know if you
have courage you should be willing to
change your mind on something that you
couldn't imagine changing your mind on
and so the idea that you can have a
scientific theory of mentality of
thought of consciousness that didn't
simply reduce to her story about
computation about the functional
relationships between different parts of
your brain if that were possible if it
were possible not to believe that and
yet not to believe in mysterious mind
mist that penetrates and has special
relationships to neurons or to some
biochemical phenomenon if we're possible
to believe that without without being
supernatural I would love to and then it
would solve a lot of my problems about
for example during computations and what
is it like to be a conversation right
I'm Terry Deakin I began in colleges in
physics like many here probably gave it
up quicker than most became very
interested in the time in the excitement
about cybernetic theory which was going
on in the late 70s and information
theory in fact my first book was a
900-page co-authored book on the Apple 2
computer and its design absurd sort of
sidetrack I took it early on why before
I got my degree but in the late 70s I
picked up by virtue of some crazy guy in
a bookstore he says you have to read
because I was reading all this you know
cybernetics and brains and computers and
stuff he said you have to you have to
read this philosopher Charles purse I
thought he was crazy is I didn't didn't
think philosophy was worth my time and
eventually just to please this crazy guy
in the bookstore I picked up a copy of
it and started reading it and I got so
disturbed that I basically dropped out
of school for a year spent my little bit
of money to buy the the volumes that
were then available you know this is
totally out of order both volumes of his
work and struggled through it trying to
make sense of it
got my undergraduate degree writing a
thesis about this and then said okay I'm
gonna go where the papers are Charles
purses papers are buried in the library
in the Houghton library in Harvard and I
got in that remarkably they like the
paper I wrote I guess and I was going to
go on and do this philosophy stuff but
this is when Hillary was there Klein I
went to work with a guy named Israel
Schaeffler nobody was interested in it
it was the most disappointing experience
I had now it turns out that first has
become a big topic since then but at the
time nobody was interested and I was I
was just crushed and I went to MIT hung
out with people like Chomsky and photo
Aaron got even more angry and I met a
guy there who was a close to retirement
a neuroscientist who had discovered some
of the first tracer techniques for
looking at connections in the nervous
system now I've been studying their
nervous system you know papers and books
as you know as a side issue and I was
younger and Sur took me on and sweet old
guy from his name was volley Nauta and
we began to I began to get more and more
involved in neurosciences and eventually
sort of jumped ship into a new program
in in biological anthropology but my
real interest was to do neuroscience in
an evolutionary way I use this new tool
to do sort of evolutionary neuroscience
by comparing the circuitry in different
brains and I began my career in that
direction is sort of you know leaning to
this other dark side and spend a lot of
time doing tracing studies and monkeys
and rats and cats and things like that
through the 90s trying to sort of get a
sense of how nervous systems had changed
by the late 90s I left Harvard and got a
position Harvard Medical School in
Boston University and began using a new
technique that I thought would tell us
more about the evolution which is
cross-species transplantation but you
can take neurons from embryonic brains
from one species and stick it in another
brain and say okay no what's it doing
and one of the nice things about that is
that the the proteins are all different
there
there they effectively the same but
they're different enough that you can
use an antibody to look at them and so
we were able to watch in effect
literally watch axons find their targets
in different rains and so I've most of
the work that I did was using Pig
fetuses into rats and monkeys and
eventually it turns out in humans and it
was wonderful we could watch this
connections being made and you know you
if you want to study the quote
computation of the brain you need to
know what's connected to what and so it
seemed to me yes yes I didn't do it I
was not allowed of course but we had
developed this technique that we had
shown worked in rats and monkeys and and
we had shown that in the rats it
actually we gave them Parkinson's
disease basically what this is from the
the frozen addicts story we learned that
there was a you know a drug that you
could give to rats or monkeys and they
would become parkinsonian and then the
question was could we cure it you know
could we stick neurons in these brains
and in fact yes we could it was
remarkable and so eventually I cut the
company Genzyme bought bought the patent
so to speak
we got nothing except we get to do our
experiments you know the usual thing
they I think they sold it for huge
amounts of money and they they actually
transplanted 12 12 individuals as quote
safety trials the sad news is that by
the time they were doing this I knew
that all the grafts were gonna be
rejected but I had signed a
nondisclosure agreement and all this
stuff and it went ahead there were
actually two real successes in that for
a very short period of time eventually
everybody rejected their grafts or they
died these were mostly fairly old people
we had one man actually the very first
one we transplanted interestingly enough
he was Jewish and he had to go to his
rabbi to discuss the question as to
whether having pig cells in his brain
would somehow violate
and and the rabbi being the the sensible
man said well you didn't eat it did you
it's okay I don't see anything you know
in the scripture said you can't do this
and so he went to and he was actually
the most successful case he was frozen
literally for the last couple of years
of his life had been basically spending
his time in a bed or a chair and he
actually during the first six to eight
months afterwards began to get up and
get around he tried to practice golf
again he painted his front porch and put
up a gate and stuff like that eventually
didn't make it but it was his remarkable
learnings that we found and the reason
that we were able to do this is that it
became clearer and clearer that no
matter where we put the appropriate
cells we know what kind of cells they
were from where you take it in the brain
wherever we put it the axons found
appropriate targets or what we might
call homologous targets and and they
would do so if we put them in the wrong
place and what that was telling us is
that across species that are as
different as as pigs and rats and
monkeys and humans that the same you
might call guidance molecules were
available and so it raised an
interesting question the question I had
been pursuing having to do with what
molecular biologists had not gone this
far by the 1990s but we have begun to
find a lot of really conserved features
but certainly for all over the cerebral
cortex we didn't know and we still don't
know exactly what guides these axons to
particular specific targets but anyway
we were able to find out we actually
could see that not only they found their
targets but we could actually see that
the synapses were functioning and so on
and by e/m so it was a remarkable
finding but it basically said that
what's different about human brains is
not that and and part of my work in
anthropology and neuroscience was to try
to get the questions what's different
about human brains compared to other
brains and how is that the brains
evolved that's sort of what drove my
work all through the 90s I left that
work in about 2000
transplanted myself out to the west
coast of Berkeley and it just it was
just after this what I felt was a
debacle in which I had signed a
nondisclosure agreement and I knew that
all these both safety trials were not
going to help the people who thought
they're you know like everybody else
who's like this they expect they're
gonna maybe be the lucky one and so I
basically sort of backed away from that
work and just went back to comparative
work but it also let me gave me a chance
to go back to earlier questions and
these are questions that that sort of
purse and his philosophy brought up for
me and in the study of brain evolution
and how brains change this question
about the emergence of new structure and
new function human language of course
being one of these classic examples of
something that just doesn't seem to have
any nice neat correlates early on in
other species using totally different
parts of the brain to communicate than
other species do it really caught my
attention but it wasn't it isn't it what
we call an emergence question now what's
interesting is that and this is where it
fits in with this group because of my
work in human evolution human origins
and cognition in a sort of indirect way
I became invited again and again to
various quasi religious groups I became
someone that the the Townsend not so
much I was in the Templeton group kept
calling to come to these various
meetings and and I would and in fact one
of the very first ones I came to we were
all talking about what we did and I and
I basically said well no I you know I'm
not an atheist I'm an anti theist
and it got everybody very upset and we
had great conversations and it turns out
that what I learned is that there's a
huge interest in quote emergentism and
people like peacock and others that many
of you may know about sort of try to
promote this idea was that sort of God
of the gaps for some people but it was
also maybe a way out for those who were
looking for a sort of compatibilism and
so I've been again and again invited to
these
and I had been asked to publish papers
in many of their books and that sort of
thing and so it's been a wonderful
dialogue I find that there is an
interest in this question that we're
about to struggle with that's in even
not the the fundamental Fiat theology
but in people at self for example I just
got an award from a Unitarian group
called the Institute for religion in the
age of science and they gave me a reward
for this current book I just produced
and because they're interested in these
questions these are these are not the
sort of hardliners but the people are
sort of you know almost secularists it
so it's a very interesting issue so let
me just say that a couple of things
about what I'm interested in what I
could change my mind about first of all
right now I'm very much interested in
rethinking the very concept of
information I think we have a remarkably
powerful physical and logical theory of
information that dates from Claude
Shannon of course but of course it has
nothing to say about reference has
nothing to say about anything normative
now when you provide information to me
there's a normative feature there and in
biology our understanding of information
both has reference and normativity so
that the Shannon model is not good
enough and so I've been struggling to
make sense of this idea in evolutionary
biology and and I think it's really a
crucial question and for the origins of
life people and what what is you know
how is it that a molecule becomes about
something that's a really interesting
question we assume that that's true in
hindsight we look back but it's okay
thank you
uh-huh you philosophers I'll let you
think whatever you want
but so that's been really interesting to
me and I've been struggling with a way
to think that through and become formal
about it to really make it clear what I
think that relationship is because I
think it can be has to be something that
we can make sense of so in this respect
there's a there's a couple of things
that
I first of all think to be the case and
but I'm willing to be convinced up
number one I don't think brains are like
computers I've spent a lot of time with
brains and there and they just don't
look like computing devices to me and
and yet I'm not saying that it's not a
functionalist physical kind of story
I just don't think our understanding of
computation is big enough to accomplish
what we want to say about this now I'm
really interested in how to expand that
notion because I give all the meaning to
my computer my computers like like like
a car engine
but I've assigned various values to the
what it's doing and so on and if I'm a
computer - then who's assigning it you
know this you get the you get the same
problem sort of running back and back
and back now number of people say oh no
it's just because we're now situated in
the world what my computer situated in
the world and certainly one that runs an
arm in a factory is situated in the
world I don't find any reason to think
there's somebody home there I think
there is something more that we have to
deal with I'm willing to be convinced
that now I'm just a computer and all
this stuff is just running programs
that's one thing I'm willing to be
convinced of just but I but I need to
have good science that tells me how to
think that through the second one and
I'm glad to be in a room with a bunch of
physicists is that I don't think that
understanding mind consciousness or how
brains work requires us to do quantum
theory a whole lot of people as you
probably know you think that somehow
consciousness requires us to understand
entanglement and things like that
okay I had to hear that but you know I'm
willing to I'm willing to be convinced
that that you need to know quantum
theory to understand how brains work but
I don't think so myself we should
distinguish no between quantum physics
and quantum statistics right so yeah
quite possible that you know but quantum
statistics describe describe fundamental
physics and maybe probably don't need to
take that into account in anything on
the other hand quantum statistics may be
better than classical statistics for
understanding the kind of yeah
no I think I think you're right that the
tools certainly could be relevant but
but to understand some of these rather
strange features that we don't really
have an explanation for we have great
description of to understand why I have
this experience it seems to me to be
something that I've never felt I needed
to do now you know some I'm not a
quantum physicist so maybe I missed
something but that's that's sort of one
of my questions so i'm rebecca goldstein
and there's owen mention i was brought
up as a very good Jewish girl
and in fact come from a very Orthodox
family so the kind in which ambition
among girls was not even a problem to
conceive of it was inconceivable and my
path was pretty clear that a girl could
even that they my parents even had to
deal with an ambitious girl I mean it
was inconceivable to them it was just I
mean the most you know perhaps I would
go to college and become a kindergarten
teacher perhaps you know but I they
allowed me strangely enough to go to the
public library we were very very poor we
didn't know any books but before the
Sabbath every Friday we would get our
reading material and they allowed me
free-range and I got a book between
second and third graders and some
called our friendly Adam it just rocked
my world
and that was what you know the world out
there is nothing the way it seems to be
there are there are no colors there are
no you know it's all and there are these
heroes they're called
scientists they're called physicists and
somehow they are able to get out there
and they were able to describe the way
the world really is and I my greatest
hope was that I would someday meet us on
my chest and be able to talk to the
camera and ask them how they did this
how they could possibly get outside
their own minds and discover the real
nature of reality so it but you know
then I was just reading as much as I
could about these things and hoping that
I would meet a scientist um the the next
thing I read that that rocked my my
little world was probably about 12 years
old my parents still hadn't caught on to
the fact that the library was the most
dangerous place in the world that I was
um Bertrand Russell's why I am NOT a
Christian and it's so good it works on
Jews I mean it's
so uh you know and for those who say
that people in this room and Beyond who
write atheist books are just you know
preaching to the higher that it doesn't
make a difference
false false false you know especially
for young people who are asking these
questions you know that that that
article yeah it just completely changed
my mind and I was going to get to
college one way or the other when I did
get to college you know it was again
philosophy was not something to major in
it was it was known in my world is very
very dangerous and subversive so and
besides I wanted to be not just to meet
a scientist but then at that point to be
a scientist and to be a physicist and I
started out with that intention and it
was pond of mechanics it was a lot of
mechanics that did it I kept going to my
professor and asking him you know what
does it mean what is it saying about our
world and he was of the school of just
shut up and and calculate and um then he
finally said to me I was at Columbia why
don't you go talk to one of the
philosophers they asked this sort of
question so I went and I spoke to Sidney
Morgan besser conversation we went out
to dinner we spoke late into the night
and at the end he convinced me that I
should go into philosophy of science and
I I live to forgive him but I
and then I you know I went on I went to
Princeton I was very and I want you to
do foundations of quantum mechanics that
was the thing that had gotten me
interested in philosophy when I got to
Princeton at that time there really was
nobody to work with on that the person
in philosophy of science was Carl temple
Peter Hempel wonderful man but he was
not willing
to work on foundations of quantum
mechanics and I was I was floundering
and then I read Tom make Oh Tom Nagel
was there and Tom I read Tom nagels what
does it like to be a bat and I this was
a problem that had really bothered me
how does that you know I was a firm -
materialist but how was it that it feels
like something to be this brain why does
it feel like something and and here you
know and he was putting it into a
language that you know I appreciate it I
thought he was making the problem quite
clear and I and I didn't work with him I
now look back in and I see that my move
away from religion has come in stages
and that was he had another stage and in
the process anyways he got the doctor it
became a philosopher I don't know how I
became a novelist to check you the truth
you know it still surprises me I was
always thinking meta philosophically my
philosophy seems to me such a strange
subject I kind of wandered into us
because of problems and trying to
interpret physics and what has so
impressed me about philosophy and
philosophical conversations are the
intuitions that people bring to bear on
philosophical core intuitions deep down
intuitions about free will or about the
objectivity of moral judgments or
certain things that they are unwilling
to forego and they'll change everything
around them but keep those core
intuitions and so that when you get down
to it you know you can make a lot of
headway with people who share your
intuitions and not so much with people
who don't share your intuitions and that
that aspect of it has the character
aspect
of it the fact that you know in
philosophy we're probably either dealing
with proto scientific questions we
haven't yet reached the science and so
we're just kind of floundering or maybe
they're really not empirically
resolvable you know that is something
that's open to me I don't know what
these philosophical questions are but
whatever they are they leave a lot of
room for one's entire character to kind
of bubble up and provide one with
intuitions so that aspect his interest
in me so much and there was no place to
deal with that in philosophy and it
drove me to write these philosophical
novels as a way of trying to show how
character is in play those philosophical
intuitions that's the best explanation I
can give for why I sometimes write these
these philosophical novels and you know
and sometimes go back and write other
things I love me I published my first
novel of mind body problem when I was
very young and basically my
philosophical career with it it was like
you know when in the day when out you
know when I had entered in it was hard
enough to be a young woman in philosophy
of science you know always the only
woman now at least there's someone
another woman but he's the only woman in
the room especially yeah when it was
full of you know what anything
philosophy science philosophy of math
was also one of my major and
mathematical logical medical one of my
major interests so but you know and then
you publish a novel a sexy novel you
might as well go around with a sign
saying I am I'm not serious serious
frivolous creature so you know anyway
that will that's how I ruin my career
and what am I most what can I one of my
interest in having my mind changed about
so many things
philosophy of math is a major issue for
me and it is the kind of thing that
sticks yes yes that's the matte you know
I wrote a book on girdles incompleteness
theorems girdle seem to think that his
theorems may be implied is too strong a
term but strongly suggested mathematical
realism I'm quite convinced by that I
would like to be unconvinced by that I'd
also like to be unconvinced of my view
that we that philosophical issues can't
be resolved and we're basically coming
at it with these you know with our whole
world being with are a hole in her life
and that they are you know deep in our
core I would like to be able to talk to
somebody who has very different
intuitions than I do
and either convince them of my Norman or
be convinced by theirs and see that
their progress can actually be made in
philosophy I'm not convinced to can be
like none of us are very good at
choosing
okay I'm damn Dennett and I didn't have
a scientific education I came from a
family going back some generations of
people in the humanities English
teachers historians my father was a
historian I was interested in science in
school but I was not particularly
encouraged and didn't do any science as
an undergraduate really did the minimal
amount it was only when I but I did work
with Quine who became my hero and mentor
and when I got to graduate school in
Oxford I got interested well I was
always interested in the mind and how it
worked and I had this bizarre eccentric
idea that it might help to know
something about the brain and this was
regarded by my fellow graduate students
as weird beyond belief I remember in
particular a discussion about what
happens for your when your arm goes to
sleep you know and you wake up to find
your hand sort of alien hand on your
face or something and I said well first
of all let's find out just what's going
on in the nervous system and and there's
and they looked at me as if I'd said
first thing to do was get clear about
you know the mineral rights in China you
know they didn't see any reason to
explore these issues and I thought well
I tried just got to do that and I began
to educate myself this was an Oxford in
the Radcliffe Science Library and spent
much more time there than I did in the
philosophy so faculty library and got my
tutor my supervisor was Gilbert Ryle it
wasn't a scientific bone in his body but
he somehow thank goodness he sort of
respected what I was doing and he
directed me to some good people to be
tutors and advisers and that began my
completely well too
I'm autodidact is in one sense true but
actually is much better than that
because I learned just enough about
neuroscience and didn't call it that in
those days so that when I got to my
first job out at Irvine in 65 and we
can't tie him to the cycle biologists
there were basically neuroscientists
they were amazed that I knew what I did
they never encountered a philosopher
that was interested in new and so they
took it upon themselves to educate me
and I've had a world-class list of
tutors in psychology neuroscience
evolutionary biology computer science
none of which have ever studied formally
but I've had really superb education
from them but all of course of this sort
of informal autodidact sort so that's
how I got to where do what I do and I
don't spend much time with philosophers
these days I don't actually let me say I
think this is a wonderfully chosen group
when I think of all the people in the
field of philosophy that aren't here i'm
so glad they're not we don't all agree
as you will soon see but but but we're
all very much in one corner of of the
discipline in our interest in and
respect for naturalism and science and
like oh and I am just appalled to see
how in spite of what I think is the
progress we've made in the last 25 years
there's this sort of retrograde gang
including some young ones then they're
going back to old-fashioned armchair
philosophy of mind with relish and an
eagerness and it just it's just
sickening because their work isn't worth
anything and they lure in other people
to do it it's it's cute it's clever and
it's not worth it am
no work that's not neither cute nor
clever and it's quite calm next well
there's that yes so yeah but just going
around the table here all the issues
that have been raised or ones that
deeply important to me and I have a lot
to say about some of them before Alex
hope in his mouth I'd already written
the first thing I wrote down on the page
what I was gonna talk about is manifest
image scientific image I am in fact I
believe that Wilfred sellers nailed it
he described the job of philosopher but
the one that is a respectable and
valuable service and that is helping
people with their intuitions about how
the manifest image goes together with
the scientific image we know it doesn't
go easily
and ever since Eddington and his two
tables and there's lots of scientists
who have tried and scientists aren't
particularly good at it and philosophers
aren't particularly good at it either if
they don't know the science what I think
you have to do is appreciate just how
you have to appreciate where the
manifest image came from how come there
is a manifest image what first I have
more to say about this later
there is the manifest image of the tick
font excuse kryb that it's the it's the
velvet it's the behavioral in fact
there's that the manifest image of
people is very different from the
manifest image of anteaters or birds for
instance but it's as much a biological
fact about people at the manifest images
that's the world we live in and that's
that's the world of of colors and other
people and and rules and tables and
chairs and
sunsets and all the rest the the
everyday common-sense world and the
scientific image is that does not go
under registration with that at all well
and the Trib you somebody's job many
people's job to help nudge these two
images into greater Concilium but help
put them together I think that's the
best thing for a philosopher to do and
that's what I take myself to be doing
now Alex thinks that the manifest image
scientific image is not a valuable you
think it's not a defensible distinction
that will be a topic for for a little
later but but I will first want to try
to show some of the positive things to
be said about the manifest image and how
it fits so many philosophers doing your
project why not basically make
pronouncing impossibilities now yeah oh
it's it's it's in addition to sellers
famous remark about how things are the
broadest sense of things hang together
in the broadest sense of hang together
there's also a line about what
philosophy is that I like and that is a
flush is what you're doing when you're
not sure you're asking the right
questions think about it we we know
scientists who it makes you it makes her
teeth it's real they don't want it but
they want to get their questions cut and
dried and hanging on the rack and then
they go answer them and so there's that
side so yes we're all we're all in this
room in that sense we're all
philosophers I think Owen has the
naturalization of ethics as a big area
and I first of all I thought his this
book on the really hard problems
a very positive review of that I think
we can make progress on this and I think
that and I've been thinking this for
years down down at the bottom of the
barrel the issue that is most pivotal is
free will
I've found neuroscientists who and Terry
almost said it I sort of if my brains a
computer I don't see how I can have free
will so I guess the brain isn't the
computer he didn't say that
but no but but but he raised the issue
in a way that I hope we will explore
further the issue about truth has come
up and it's interesting that there are
some philosophers and scientists who
have arrived at the position that
believing in free will is so important
that we should foster this as a holy
myth even though it ain't true if I
found myself in that camp I'd be in deep
trouble but in fact I find myself in the
camp saying but actually once you
understand what freewill is and what it
has to be in order to make life side
meaning there's no conflict at all it's
it's not a holy myth it's the it's the
literal non-metaphorical truth that that
compatibilism is true but it's it's a
little bit more convoluted story then as
often been now functionalism and
homunculus functionalism years ago I
said inspired really by working AI at
the time that I was working on here's
the way to do the mind you start with a
whole big mind you break it down into a
few sub minds that are that are that are
think of them as homunculus they're sort
of agencies they have their own agendas
to a certain scent they have their own
specialization they interact it's a sort
of social interaction of these sub minds
and they in turn are made of sub sub
Minds which
sup sup sup lines so you get this
cascade of agencies down finally you get
two little machines little little agents
that can be replaced by a machine and at
the time I was thinking that's the
neuron that's the I was inspired by the
McCulloch Pitts logical neuron now of
course we know that McCulloch fits
logical neurons are due laughably too
simple now I'm still a homunculus
unction lyst
but I think we have to take seriously
that neurons are selfish neurons to
quote Sebastian Seung and and teri was
talking about the way they send out
their dendritic explorations my view now
which I'm willing to be changed about
her I like that perhaps change Terry's
mind about is that the brain is a
largely anarchic assemblage of selfish
neurons which can form coalition's and
cabal's and interact that you have to
take their their agendas seriously and
then you get a model of computation
which is profoundly unlike the model
that handles the lab it's still
computation because as alex says it's an
information or or as Don was saying it's
an information informational processing
system but it's also a sort of an
economic system in a certain way so that
we save the idea of the brain as a
computer we save functionalism by
abandoning a rigid hierarchical Eric
bomb computer scientist has a great word
for the mistake and architecture she
calls them politbureau architectures
which i think exactly captures what's
wrong with the standard image of
computation in the brain so what I would
be interested to see if anybody can
change my mind about is
the manifest image I think that it's not
just Pro Tam that we've got the manifest
image and that we can we all start there
and then we move off into a scientific
image which simply abandons the manifest
image I think once we understand how the
manifest image arises the roles it plays
in in life including the life of the
scientist we see that we want to clarify
the relationships between the manifest
image and the scientific image and
although the scientific image has
priority in one sense it doesn't usurp
the the ground of the manifest image at
the end of the day Oh Rebecca said you
know you know there's no colours in one
sense there's no colours atoms aren't
colored just like a magnetic radiation
visible spectrum so forth but there's
another sense which requestors colors I
mean if you say hey there's no color
television set in my hotel room and they
say well of course not because there's
no color you would think wait a minute
there's a sense which it's obvious that
there's color that's in the manifest
image we've got to make sense of that I
think we have to make sense of coffee
break times and then we'll finish and
philosophers attitudes to death because
it connects just remarkable truth
company mate when I was a grad student
at the University of Western Ontario
philosophy I read brainstorm and I went
to a lot of the distinguished
philosophers in the department who I
will not name and say this is great
stuff this no this is this is philosophy
of mind I can really I mean what do you
think of this he's sick I said you
shouldn't really take n it seriously as
a philosopher because there's there's
almost no proper analytical
in there and I said but but what if it
might be true right he's no who cares
who knows this fetishization of truth is
definitely something we do do I'm still
the truth fetishes myself alright so in
the interest of not running beyond the
coffee break line let's just break the
coffeemaker back
you